I think that's a very American question
I mean I think that many societies
wouldn't even pose it that way and it
reflects the fact that American history
although it's had it's unfortunate
periods has been basically an incredibly
happy story again not for all Americans
but if you think of sort of where the
United States began in 1776 and where it
ended up in 2007 it's a remarkable run
of success and it's partly because we
did some things right and it's also
partly because we got very lucky in
where the country was located the fact
that the native population turned out to
be very susceptible to disease that was
brought over from Europe the fact that
the European countries kept beating each
other up while we sat here and became
more productive so we've been very
fortunate so we have this view of the
world that everything tends to go well
and therefore your question you know how
can we solve all these problems so this
happy story continues well of course it
hasn't been as happy a story for you
know Russia throughout the 20th century
for much of Europe which destroyed
itself twice in the 20th century other
parts of the world don't tell white the
same happy story so him the first thing
I would say is all right we shouldn't be
expecting perfection we're not going to
be solving all of these problems and
it's not like bad things will never
happen to Americans or to other people
we want to try to do the best we can
within the facing the set of problems
that we now face and with the set of
resources at our disposal the sort of
step one is be realistic about what we
think we can accomplish and then start
you know ticking off the various
problems and so you're working on them I
think Americans again tend to think of
it as sort of I want a perfect answer
because I'm an American citizen and I'm
entitled to live for 85 years in
relatively good health and in a pretty
comfortable house with a pretty nice
family it's not the way it really works
even in America the second thing that we
have to remind ourselves as a country
that knowledge turns out to be a good
thing that we ought to be basing our
policy decisions
to the extent that we can on robust
analysis on the best available expertise
on on fax you know what people call
reality based analysis it's troublesome
when you read about a president who says
you know he likes to go on his gut
instincts nobody's got instincts are
that good and one of the things that has
allowed us to get to where we are today
as a country but I think also more
broadly in the world has been to to
prise knowledge to prize research to
place a lot of social resources in that
in that place and encourage people to
pursue ideas as much as they can and
it's I think very short-sighted for any
society when it starts sort
shortchanging its intellectual community
or when it starts ruling certain ideas
out of court and saying no you can't
work on that you shouldn't write that
you shouldn't say that
that's what strangles human creativity
and we're gonna need some creative
solutions to address the various
problems we've already talked about
again we get that by valuing
intellectuals of all kinds natural
scientists philosophers artists etc but
also giving them lots of freedom to
explore ideas